8 news now or next our media group
we need to close the the southern border
where the caravans are coming in
millions of people are coming in is is
focus number one
tonight on politics now republican
congressional candidate sam peters talks
to us about immigration the economy and
abortion plus
you can also expand the court like
roosevelt tried to do during the new
deal
congresswoman dina titus talks to us
about some recent supreme court
decisions and her own political race
what we're looking for
is
you know the impacts
of drug policy
on individuals
plus pot lounges rules for nevada and
how the state decides who gets a lounge
license
from eight news now
this is politics now
thank you for joining us here on
politics now i'm john langler and we
start with the primary election
republican gubernatorial candidate joey
gilbert is formally requesting a
statewide recount gilbert lost the
republican primary to clark county
sheriff joe lombardo by 26 thousand
votes now gilbert claims there was fraud
although he's provided no evidence
gilbert had to pay the 190 thousand
dollars to pay for the recount he had to
do that up front he'll only get a refund
if he wins and the recount is already
underway
so while for some the primary election
remains unsettled other candidates are
focused on november's general election
tonight we look at the congressional
races in district four incumbent
democrat stephen horsford faces
republican challenger sam peters peters
ran for that seat back in 2020 and he
lost i sat down with sam peters to talk
about abortion immigration and the
economy
let's talk a little bit about your
background you're a veteran you have an
insurance business here in town what
about your experience
qualifies you or do you think would be
good assets to bring to congress yeah so
i did i spent 20 years in the military i
joined the military right out of high
school
i was an enlisted guy for 10 years i was
a law enforcement canine handler so i
did police work with a dog
and then i commissioned i earned my
degrees i've got a degree in criminal
justice a master's degree in
administration i learned earned those
along the way i was offered a commission
by the air force and i worked as an
officer i led people i led organizations
i worked on the federal budget the
palming process to build the president's
budget from the bottom up so i know how
that practice works i also worked on
projects to support security at the
southern border so i have a back
background in those type of things
i spent time in iraq and afghanistan i
led people in in those areas i earned a
bronze star in afghanistan as well
when i retired i started a small
business i'm a small business owner i
also have small children that are you
know we're homeschooling at this time at
this point um so there's a lot of people
pieces in my background that fit
together that come together you know the
us constitution says law and finance are
the responsibility of the u.s house of
representatives and that's what i'm
that's what i'm running for the recent
decision by the supreme court to
overturn roe v wade
you're pro-life anti-abortion pretty
much
go ahead no you guys you'll have the
anti-abortion that's a little that's a
little stretch but let's clarify about
that yeah fair enough so let's clarify
are there any circumstances where you
believe an abortion
is okay so my abortion stance has been
on my website for three years um it's
sampeters4congress.com you can go out
and take a look at it i am a supporter
of uh the pain-capable child protection
act which is which limit goes to a
20-week time frame um so uh the
democrats have already in fact as soon
as i won the primary they came out
labeled me in certain ways anti-abortion
being one of them there are
circumstances where uh it is appropriate
uh and the rhetoric now that
sam peters wants to uh strip
women of their rights to health care is
an absolute falsehood uh and i'm not
gonna allow that uh that to pervade so
um the reality of it is uh the roe
versus weight overturn had zero effect
on nevada law uh the naval law was put
in place in carson city and if it's
going to change that's where it's going
to change again one of the aspects of
your campaign you talk about a balanced
budget amendment
explain what you would like to try and
bring to congress on that yeah so a
balanced budget dimension just simply
means that we don't spend more money
than we have to spend we we have or we
keep it within a margin of of of
inflation
you know right now
all a lot of the bills coming out of
congress and
the senate you know you're looking at
trillion dollar spending bills and the
trillion dollar spending bills are not
spending the money where the title of
the bill would lead you to believe and
the reality of it is the u.s house again
is responsible for all things law and
finance which includes passing a federal
budget which hasn't been done since 1997
so you could not come to work for 25
years not do your job and still have a
job and that's what we're talking about
with with balanced budgets and making
sure look we have a 30 trillion dollar
debt it's not sustainable it's going up
every single year and every single year
we're looking at raising the debt
ceiling to allow more debt that plays
into this inflationary environment and
what's you know six dollars seven
dollars eight dollars gas that's coming
and it's and it's something that we have
to get ahead of quickly we just saw the
tragedy down in near san antonio this
week a horrible situation dozens of
people that died being brought into the
country
uh you talk about finishing the wall
there's there's other elements of
immigration that you mentioned you'd
like to tackle what do you think is the
the most important thing that you would
like to do if you're elected right away
close the border just close it just
close the border we don't know the
people that have the southern and
northern eastern the all yeah we need to
close the the southern border where the
caravans are coming in millions of
people are coming in is is focus number
one we have to get a handle on no
question all of these other borders as
you mentioned because it's you know all
of our ports our international airports
the northern border becomes
is can become a problem as well if
people are trying to come in illegally
and we just we shore up one border and
people start coming through another
that's obviously a problem so yes we
have to we've had over two million or
nearly two million illegal immigrants
come into the country people that we
know of uh there's been a number of that
we don't know of obviously and you know
the people that are coming into the
country represent over a hundred
countries from around the world many of
them on the terror watch list and
they're coming through the southern
border through mexico so one of the
things that i would do is like i
mentioned we need to close the border we
need to finish the wall
our entire interview with sam peters is
on eightnewsnow.com including the
changes that he would like to see in the
military as you mentioned he is a
veteran
going forward congressman stephen
horsford does have a big fundraising
advantage on peter's more than 2 million
dollars in cash on hand peters has a
little more than 80 thousand dollars
right now
from abortion to the environment
democrats are furious with several
recent supreme court decisions
congresswoman dina titus is also up for
reelection in a newly redrawn
congressional district one this week we
spoke with her about those rulings and
how it affects the campaign
what discussions
have you had with your
fellow democrats on capitol hill
not only about the decision itself but
maybe a response
from the democratic side
well it's difficult to overturn anything
the supreme court does that's why this
is such a monumentous terrible decision
it was shocking that you turned back 50
years of constitutional rights but not
surprising given this court there's a
lot of conversation about creating haven
states states that have some protections
for abortion and don't have those
trigger laws that will automatically go
into effect and some talk about having
allowing abortions on public lands but i
think that's a little more difficult to
put in place we want to be sure that
there's funding for
uh birth control
in states where people might be going
because they can't get a divorce
abortion at home and plus you'll need
more birth control as as you uh plan
your future given the uncertainty of
what the court might do even if there
was an appetite among the democrats to
try and do something legislatively in
washington
i get the sensation it wouldn't go very
far anywhere else so
is there is there anything that can be
done
well
yes there are some things we could do
away with the filibuster this will pass
out of the house it's in the senate then
it gets stuck where it takes 60 votes
that's just a rule it's not in law it's
not in the constitution you can get rid
of the filibuster and then you can move
a lot of things like the pro-act or some
gun legislation or equality act so
that's one thing you can do you can also
expand the court like roosevelt tried to
do during the new deal but that will be
uh more difficult i believe
is that something you would support
i would certainly look at it uh if you
expand the court then the democratic
president could make some more
appointments it seems to me ridiculous
that six people six people imposed their
own will and their own beliefs on the
whole country when the great majority of
people in this country support keeping
grow intact when you get back to uh
washington
obviously you're also in the middle of a
re-election campaign how
how much of a of an issue will these
decisions be when you're on the campaign
trail and and your fellow democrats on
the campaign trail they'll be very
important uh certainly they energize the
base women are very fired up about the
abortion decision environmentalists care
very much about clean air and clean
water as does everybody but they're the
active ones you know that the gun lobby
will wants to keep the
keep things out of uh statute that
like my bump stock bill that they didn't
include in the senate bill but the other
side with the gabby giffords group and
the brady group they're gonna be all
fired up so i think these are energizing
uh issues and if you look at me and my
opponent or democrats and some of their
crazy republican opponents you'll be
able to present a real contrast to the
voters so they can really make a choice
you can see our full interview with
congresswoman titus 8 newsnow dot com
like the other democratic incumbents
congresswoman titus has a big
fundraising advantage right now she has
nearly 1.3 million dollars in cash on
hand mark robertson her opponent has
about 130 thousand dollars right now
one of the men arrested for his one of
the las vegas man arrested for his role
in the january 6th insurrection says
he's guilty 32 year old nate degrave
took a plea deal this week degrave spoke
exclusively with our i-team last year
saying he was innocent and also said he
wants to run for mayor he faces several
years in prison meanwhile the
congressional committee investigating
the january 6th capitol hill riot are
still holding their hearings
next on politics now ballot initiatives
moving forward we'll take a look at the
rent control vote on the upcoming ballot
and another initiative that would change
how elections are run in nevada
plus one step closer to pot lounges
nevada's first rules and regulations
live local now
welcome back to politics now
three nevada state supreme court
decisions are shaping the november
ballot we'll start with what will be on
it open primaries and ranked choice
voting if approved by moving forward it
would allow people to vote for a
republican or a democrat or anyone else
instead of only having to vote for their
registered party ranked choice is where
candidates give an order of preferred
candidates and the top five move on in
the ballot box the other initiatives
lost at the supreme court and will not
be on the ballot the teachers union was
allowed to pull gaming tax and sales tax
initiatives off the ballot that money
would have gone to education
also a school choice initiative which
would have led students use money
allocated for public schools
at private schools that lost there
simply wasn't a way to pay for it so
essentially was an unfunded mandate
the culinary union has turned in the
signatures to get a rent control
initiative in north las vegas on the
november ballot it would prevent any
increases for a year and then capped
them at the cost of living governor
steve siselek says if this passes he
would try and bring up rent control
during the 2023 legislative session
meanwhile the culinary union is blaming
rising rental prices on corporate greed
short-term mental corporations massive
investments and then they corner the
market and they're jacking up the rent
because they can solution is we've got
to stop them with neighborhood stability
in a statement the nevada state
apartment association says any
initiative to cap rents has never
provided sound or effective solutions
the culinary union's refusal to meet
with the rental housing industry it
continues will negatively impact north
las vegas its residents and its economic
diversification efforts
it has been five years since the first
recreational marijuana dispensary opened
here in nevada and now our state's
getting closer to having a place for
people to legally smoke it we could see
the first pot lounges open by the end of
the year rules and regulations for them
were approved by the cannabis compliance
board this week joe mola reports
there isn't a legal place to smoke it
frank hawkins owns nevada wellness
center we have a dispensary on the
bottom
consumption lounge is on the top tuesday
he learned more about the rules and
regulations that are now in place for
future lounges something he has been
setting up for in the upstairs of the
building next we'll be opening up the
consumption lounge after more than a
dozen public workshops the board voted
on finalizing the cannabis lounge
regulations and the rules for the
application process over the next few
months they expect to have informational
workshops before the application process
opens and then we'll send a 30-day
notice out
will initiate
so 30-day notice for an open application
period cannabis compliance board
executive director tyler klimas says
they expect 40 to 45 applications for
lounges attached to retail shops and 20
independent shops 10 of which will go to
social equity applicants climates
explained what that means what we're
looking for the impacts
of drug policy
on individuals and members of the
community
and so we're looking at
poverty level
we're looking at any kind of past
convention convictions for cannabis just
some of the regulations include safety
protocols at lounges training
requirements for staff and location
requirements for the lounges that
include certain distances from locations
such as schools and community facilities
hawkins is now one step closer to
getting a lounge open the consumption
lounges are going to go a long way for
making a difference joe mohler live
local now
next on politics now protection for
abortions the executive orders from
governor sissel act which protect
abortions for tourists specifically
plus policy at the border the supreme
court ruling that gets rid of the remain
in mexico policy what it means for other
immigration laws
day starting at 4 on 8 news now
you're watching politics now
democrats have started challenging their
republican opponents to debates for the
november election governor steve sisilak
has proposed two debates with sheriff
joe lombardo one at each end of the
state lombardo says he will work on some
mutually agreeable times venues and
moderators senator catherine cortez
masto has proposed three debates with
her republican challenger adam laxalt
both asked for at least one of the
debates to be broadcast on spanish
language television
this week governor steve sisilak signed
executive orders to protect women who
come to nevada for abortions
i'm going to do everything i can to make
sure that we can protect women women
that come here
to access medical care that they're not
subject to any prosecution any arrest if
a state tries to we're not going to
cooperate in terms of providing
information to cooperate and ensure
people here professionals that are uh
in the
business of delivering you know uh
health care to women that they won't be
prosecuted for what they do that they'll
be protected by the laws of the state of
nevada
the orders create a safe haven for women
and abortion providers that come here
from across state lines governor sysolak
also commented on search warrants being
served on six state republican parties
republican party officials at beg your
pardon those people are being
investigated for a fake presidential
elector scheme
i remember when they had the fake
electric slate brought forward
and i appreciate the fact that the
federal government's trying to get to
the bottom of this and make sure that
doesn't happen our democracy was put at
risk great risk and it's unfortunate
that some people continue to buy into
that
those search warrants include one
against state republican party chairman
michael mcdonald so far though no
charges have been brought
the last decision of the supreme court
in this pre most recent term included
getting rid of our remain in mexico
policy alex simone from our washington
d.c bureau broke down the decision
joining us to talk about the last
supreme court decision of the session
alex simone from our washington d.c
bureau
alex the supreme court says the biden
administration could end former
president trump's remaining mexico
policy at the border let's talk first
about the policy itself
yeah this policy was when president
trump enacted it actually officially
called the migrant protections protocols
or mpp but became more widely known as
the remain in mexico policy and that's
because what it did is allow the federal
government to force asylum seekers to
remain in mexico while they awaited
their asylum hearings and as you know
that's a process that can be very very
lengthy because of the backlog in our
immigration court systems and so we saw
those kind of tent cities spring up
along the mexico side of the border and
president biden had had vowed to rescind
that policy because he and democrats and
humanitarian organizations saw it as a
very inhumane policy that
allowed asylum seekers who were already
you know saying that they were fleeing
danger to
be put in danger once again there were
actually
a lot of documented cases and data that
showed that these asylum seekers were
subjected to violence kidnappings rapes
and just other sorts of attacks while
they remained in mexico and waited for
their asylum cases to be heard and so
president biden had vowed
to rescind this policy and that's what
he was attempting to do and now the
supreme court has cleared the way for
him to end that policy yeah as you
mentioned so the biden administration
argued it kind of affected uh their
relationship with regards to uh those at
the border uh which certainly would be
challenging here what's the next steps
moving forward
so officially uh this case has to go
back to the lower courts for some
procedural issues but really the supreme
court has cleared the way for the
administration
to end the policy what we're now kind of
keeping an eye on is how this could
affect
other policies more broadly and so while
you know on a narrow basis this again
does say that the biden administration
didn't break the law or violate the way
that these policies are supposed to be
ended
more broadly what it does is return that
immigration authority back to the
divided administration and to the
federal government which is where
immigration issues have always
lied and so
what the supreme court is essentially
saying here is that the states don't
have that type of power to make
immigration rules or laws
so it will be interesting to see whether
that same idea is more broadly
applied to other cases like for example
title 42 because that's really the case
that has kept virtually all asylum
seekers out of the united states and has
given the government
basically
forced the government to turn away all
asylum seekers nearly all of them with
few exceptions like unaccompanied minors
because of the pandemic and for public
health reasons
and that was alex simone from washington
d.c
this week judge katanji brown jackson
became the first black woman to sit on
the supreme court she is now the
nation's
116th justice replacing retiring justice
stephen breyer the appointment isn't
going to change the ideological makeup
of the conservative leaning court but it
is certainly history
will nevada be the first state to
nominate a president in 2024 on the
democratic side we're going to tell you
about next week's key vote next
adobe brogue.com
this week in what to watch monday is the
fourth of july and as we celebrate our
country's independence there's plenty of
events politicians will be out and about
the two biggest events the patriotic
parade in summerlin and boulder city's
danbury also next friday and saturday
we'll expect the first recommendation on
whether nevada becomes the first state
in the 2024 democratic presidential
nominating process
the vote will be first committee vote
will be this week a full vote is soon
afterwards just some things to watch
thank you for joining us we will see you
next time here on politics now take care
[Music]
you